so republicans are responding to joe
biden's desperate attempt to swivel away
from his failing presidency by calling
everybody a racist mitch mcconnell the
senate minority leader soon to be
majority leader again he blasted joe
biden in fiery language from the floor
of the senate here was the senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell
he compared listen to this a bipartisan
majority of senators
to literal
traitors
how
profoundly profoundly
unpresidential
look i've known
liked
and personally respected joe biden for
many years
i did not recognize
the man
at the podium
yesterday okay so first of all uh mitch
mcconnell should recognize the man at
the podium yesterday because that guy's
been in the senate saying the same sort
of stupid crap for 30 years i mean this
is a guy who said in 2012 while he was
vice president that mitt romney the
unsweetened oatmeal of politics
mitt romney
was a man so racist that he would put
black people back into chains if he was
elected president of the united states
joe biden is a congenital liar
joe biden is a corrupt politician he has
been his entire career and the the sort
of old boys club that is the senate
where everybody is best friends is
really really silly when it comes to
people like joe biden okay mitt romney
for his part he makes the point that joe
biden is going down the same road that
trump did right if you don't like trump
declaring that elections are
are questionable and you shouldn't be in
favor of joe biden saying that all
elections are questionable unless he
gets his way
he said that the goal of some
republicans is to quote turn the will of
the voters
into a mere suggestion
and so president biden goes down the
same tragic road taken by president
trump
casting doubt on the reliability of
american elections
this is a sad
sad day
i expected more
of president biden
who came into office with the stated
goal
of bringing the country together and
here's the thing about this this is
that's amazing of course joe biden is
now calling on the senate to get rid of
the filibuster joe manchin kirsten
cinema they're not going to do that but
you know who wouldn't have done that
when he was in the senate joe biden i
mean joe biden was literally asked about
this during the 2020 election cycle he
was asked will you kill the filibuster
and he was like i don't think that's a
good idea
we should make no mistake
this nuclear option
is ultimately an example
of the arrogance of power
it is a fundamental power grab
by
the majority party ending the filibuster
is a very dangerous thing to do because
it's been used by progressives the whole
our whole time to make sure that we did
not get rolled over
um okay and it's not just joe biden
who's been saying this chuck schumer
who's now all in favor of killing the
filibuster for this voting rights
nonsense
he opposed changing the filibuster like
five minutes ago this is chuck schumer
when he had a little bit more hair in
2005.
we are on the precipice of a crisis a
constitutional crisis
the checks and balances which have been
at the core of this republic
are about to be
evaporated
by the nuclear option
the checks and balances which say that
if you get 51 percent of the vote
you don't get your way a hundred percent
of the time
it is amazing it's almost a temper
tantrum
by those on the hard hard right they
want the judge they want their way every
single time
and they will change the rules
break the rules misread the constitution
so that they will get their way
chuck schumer should meet chuck schumer
by the way it's always fun to watch some
of this old footage because you see
people that you didn't realize whether
that's preet bharara uh the former
district attorney in new york uh who's
sitting next to chuck schumer used to be
his chief legal accountant anyway it's a
side note tom cotton he's senator from
arkansas he went further yesterday he
went on the floor to the senate he just
read quotes by chuck schumer
i will do everything i can to prevent
the nuclear option from being invoked
not for the sake of myself for my party
but for the sake of this great republic
and its traditions
those are powerful words
but they're not mine
every word of my speech today
was originally spoken
by our esteemed colleague
the senior senator from new york
chuck schumer
yeah yeah but
consistency is the hobgoblin of little
mind meanwhile by the way dick durbin i
mean how bad is this dick durbin he's
the senator from illinois dick turbin is
a man so radical that he suggested in
the middle of the iraq war that holding
terroristic gitmo was equivalent to nazi
concentration camps pol pot's
mistreatment of dissenters and the
soviet gulag he had to apologize for
that so dick durbin is no moderate dick
durbin yesterday's like yeah i think joe
biden went a little far saying that
everyone who opposes him is a
confederate
yes there are parallels there perhaps
the president went a little too far in
his rhetoric some of us do but the
fundamental principles and values at
stake are very very similar uh no they
they're not actually it's very similar
at all meanwhile jen saki she dismissed
criticism of joe biden she's like oh
these people were fine with trump really
was mitt romney fine with trump i missed
that part here is john saki being
shinsaki
senator rami today basically said i'll
use the exact quote that the speech
yesterday that the president gave was
going down the same tragic road take by
president trump and casting the doubt on
the reliability of american elections
does the white house ever respond to
that
with all due respect to to senator
romney i think anyone would note there's
a night and day difference between
fomenting an insurrection based on lies
totally debunked by 80 judges including
trump appointed ones and election
authorities across the country and
making objective true statements which
is what the president made yesterday
about the effects of a coordinated
nationwide effort to undermine the
constitutional right to vote the hell is
she talking about objective true
statements you're right he's just like
jefferson davis it's just like bull
connor
these people are they're insane
now the reason they have to be insane is
because if they re-enter the realm of
sanity they might be held to account for
the fact that joe biden is a terrible
terrible president they have to escape
that they have to escape the fact and
it's inescapable he is a terrible
president which is why seven in 10
american voters now think he stinks
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier
that is just science
[Music]